hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to job simulator bacon
whoo I feel good
is this hot oh it's so realistic
it's bubbling I wonder what would happen
if I whoa I didn't make me do that I
love it while my eggs are on fire
they call it Eggs Benedict oh that would
be much better than just setting it on
the dirty countertop cheese traditional
human vintage crumpets crumpets crumpets
crumpets these crumpets I don't know
what British speak means I love corn
cookie and pretzel soup naturally
artificial is it a never-ending loaf of
bread oh my god it is oh my god it never
ends looks delicious
what happens if I put olive oil in a cup
would you like that I mean you're French
you wouldn't know the difference huh I'm
going to be exactly uncreated sriracha
on a potato how about a corn cob
sandwich in a little garnish how about
an irradiated drop your welcome
everybody you having a good day
[Music]